MJ is not flying to Las Vegas and
knocking on anyone's hotel that was
crazy that it was actually Michael
Jordan - yeah now that that's done I
mean that is the greatest compliment of
all time yeah the greatest compliment of
all time is Michael Jordan knocks on
your [ __ ] hotel room when you've been
gone for 72 hours or however many hours
it was and says hey we got to get back
oh you know what I actually thought that
girls dough has more than a release for
Dennis Rodman I thought it was he needs
love again maybe more than structure he
just needs love because when he said
when Pip and came back one even Jordan
said when people was gone somebody said
when Pippen was gone
I'm Rodman MJ needed Rodman yeah and
Robin loved that Rodman says when Piven
came back I'm just back to being the
third kind of like forgotten brother and
I think that was him being like I don't
like I need love I need attention I need
whatever so I'm just gonna go cope how I
cope and then hopefully you'll come
rescue me or save me or love me or
whatever I think that's definitely part
of it hundred percent I think wanting to
feel needed it was definitely it I also
think there's something about knowing
that they could get it done without him
in the moat knowing that he didn't have
to put it all in like he comes to them
when Scotty comes back he goes I need a
vacation
yeah what does he need a vacation from
this guy someone who deals with mental
issues right he has had extreme focus
for this however many months stretch
that Scotty's down right and that
extreme focus gets them to start winning
games yeah right now Scotty's back he's
like listen I am [ __ ] mentally ill I
can't sustain this right I need to blow
off steam what is another way to not
deal with your mental issues drink party
of Medicaid self-medicate is called
self-medicating that's what the partying
is it's not I like watching girls dance
like you're a NBA player you have girls
come to your [ __ ] house whenever you
like while he's with Carmen Electra
still dancing with other coaches talking
about other [ __ ] please believe there
was more than one [ __ ] in that room
when Jordan said I'm not gonna say what
was happening in the room he's not gonna
make he was with his girlfriend
hey you think it might have been another
dude in there - who knows writing
anything slogan impossible is nothing
and nothing was good was gonna was gonna
like um weird out MJ if you yeah so so
here's the dope thing why do you think
that MJ had so much respect for Rodman I
think yeah I think cuz he saw the work I
could and he put it all out there
probably the only person other than him
who puts it all out there so it's like I
yeah I don't need to say anything - yeah
I was I was asking around a little bit
and I was like what do you think it is
like just asking some folks in a league
and one thing that is is not really
touch upon that much in the documentary
you kind of see it but they don't really
say Rodman was a gym rat oh yeah you
probably know this but like the average
person is like eyes wearing makeup and
he's out partying all the time when he
wasn't doing that he's in the gym he is
a he's the work hard play hard guy that
you've all known one like that he might
be the most the biggest example of party
hard work hard party hard work hard and
MJ was a rat yeah so when MJ saw that
Rodman was a gym rat and like every time
MJ's in the gym lifts and all of a
sudden this rodman guys also in the gym
lifting he don't got to motivate him
he's just there that's what he likes
I think he's going okay this guy's about
it he's not what maybe people say and
then when he sees him diving into the
stands literally leaving it all in the
[ __ ] floor and he goes wait I don't
got a motivate that [ __ ]
everyone else on this team I gotta yell
at them berate them and then manage
their confidence etc but this guy rodman
nothing I say to him can make him feel
one way or the other he's gonna give a
hundred percent on the floor and he's
gonna meet me in the gym the next day
yeah okay yeah I wonder if he also liked
he didn't have to stand over his
teammates if Rodman is there or at least
that's one teammate I never have to
stand up to it for I remember it was in
his first three-peat there was a series
against the Knicks where they were
getting bullied around yeah and his dad
was like you gotta you can't let them
get bullied around you got to be the guy
to stand up and fight and is that that
shot of him and Xavier McDaniels like
forehead to forehead John yep with
Rodman that's the guy [ __ ] with
everybody else he's getting call Malone
the head super badly like these guys
[ __ ] hate him and he can stand up for
himself
Scottie somebody goes in Scottie I got
to jump into the fray and it's like I'm
too valuable to be the enforcer yeah I
can't be enforcement Oakley was - yeah
and he loves Oakley as a human and
probably would have liked to have him
back on his team now I got a much better
version of Charles Oakley Anderson
listen if Dennis gets into some [ __ ]
he's the guy they're all gonna go out
cuz everybody irritates everybody and
how I got stand-up for Dennis I don't
know how don't you see I don't need that
burden
I got enough going on maybe there's
another smaller factor there no that's
that's true also he probably just
remembers playing against them on a
Pistons and like oh yeah battle that he
had to go against them every time the oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is the real
[ __ ] broke
[Applause]